fruit d'un peut pas contrôler une
machine à remonter dans j'ai vu la vidéo
on a déjà dû la fabriquer
casillas l'avion pour un deuxième chance
comme ça commence à la candeur projet
les malades si on va recommencer un truc
qu'on a loupé on ferait une deuxième
fois mais bien elle serait pas mal
l'important j'étudiais life et m'a fait
tout ça pourrait servir circulaire pas
du tout et les meufs
ouais bon jeu pour m'en servir mais
excusez moi je t'ai vu au bar et je me
suis dit ray lane est vraiment super
rebelle
ok ce qui intéresse les une fille c'est
juste son physique excuse moi je t'ai vu
tout seul au bar et je me suis cette
fleur c'est vraiment pas son physique
qui m'intéresse c'est vraiment son
mental pas du tout son physique
ok nous tenterons veut dire que je
marche à toi je t'ai vu au bar et je me
suis dit oh toi c'est pas ton physique
qui m'intéressent moutons mental aucun
des deux alors pourquoi je vais voir
ouais c'est vrai ça c'est clair ce
serait génial l'une pardon je prends un
objet tu vas tu as ta sortie d'autoroute
je pourrais revenir en arrière elle à
des cas c'est toi ouais sauf que ça se
passe et imaginaire là tu viens juste de
nick et mata sortie d'autoroute moi mais
ça aurait pu
non moi si je pouvais revenir en arrière
par exemple je fais des trucs de ouf
si les faits on reste concentré et donc
de la théorie de la relativité par le
génie voilà le grand mohammed shtayyeh
super bon alors maintenant on ouvre son
livre à la page 78 et je vais vous
parler d'un autre génie de vinci qui a
peint la joconde en 1517 un compte au
nom du 7 mai et reste tout de même un
mystère immense c'est qu'ils étaient sur
le qui-vive total à tout le monde dès
qu'un truc tout sous le pif risette with
it rezé c'est vrai qu'on pourrait
changer notre vie
repartir à zéro et éviter des heurts
puis enfin à la cgt peu de mou
ouais ouais par contre j'ai pas du tout
intéressé moi je suis bien j'aime pas
tout ce qui est femme enfant tout sépare
mon délire beaucoup tu gagnes tu juin
des coups de matraque dans la déco la
moder de jardinage bricolage une pièce à
vivre en crise
allez salut au loup salut alors moi je
vais pas du tout plaider devant très
hétéro et quand je t'ai vu je me suis
dit elle
c'est ni son physique n'est son mental
qu'on intéresse assez marrant c'est
exactement ce que je suis dit que
j'étais bien rêver et on a un point
commun et moi aussi j'aime bien roland
lui fait tant que single ça marchait pas
de meuf pas de gosses parfaits à l'eau
j'aurais pas bien sac de couches propres
non pas là non il ya mon gosse scarlett
patch l epita là c'est totalement nul ça
va tu vas pas te plaindre tout a une fin
je pourrais couché avec une nouvelle
meuf tous les soirs trop que c'est une
vie ça baisse carrément bien ouais bon
j'avoue que c'est pas forcément le bon
exemple mais relativise mon pote a fait
la plus belle chose au monde
ça c'est beau mon pote ça tu as raison
à ces mots ya un peu une tête de rabin
alors me retrouve pas maintenant quand
même une barbe